hello recheck nation on Greg Alba what's
your name
Tara Ericsson it's fine I'll do it
Tara Ericsson is back on the channel
welcome to January with the real rejects
Tara hey Tara
you act sometimes right yeah that's
right I do that she does you know I
found this video that was requested
actors who were never the same after a
role oh I'm never the same when I leave
here I inflict a lot of psychological
abuse on the guests that come on this
channel
Tara's never an exception to that No so
I'm excited to check this out because
I'm fascinated by actors I believe they
should throw themselves very much into
their roles no matter how dark but they
should lead a damn good personal life
we're also going to judge them on
Twitter let's do this let's do it this
video is about a year old so let's see
let's see if there's probably old news
here we've all had tough days in the
office but some actors dedicate Roger
Rabbit the experience of preparing for
and recovery from these roles did a
number of the actors involved and left a
lasting impression not always for the
positive here are several actors who
with the extra mile for the craft
Isabella Johnny possession any horror
buff knows the subway scene not raise
your left skis 9 - that's Reza to be one
of the most horrifying shocking moments
of body war ever to grace the silver
screen 1 if you haven't seen the film
buckle up you're in for a treat is
a césar Award for her performance but
the intense physical and emotional
demands of the role made for an
extremely difficult be cooperation a
Johnny leader told French magazine that
it took her years of therapy to get on
out of her system
and that she would never again attempt
another role like it Aaron Rudy the
pianist though Brody's physical
transformation for 2002 the pianist is
obvious the actor has also discussed the
enormous mental and emotional strain of
portraying a Holocaust survivor with
German the Academy Award for Best Actor
in 2003 shares work experiences of
making in his film made me very aware of
the sadness and the dehumanization of
people at times of war to prepare for
the role Brody gave up his apartment
sold his car disconnected his bones and
moved to Europe but it was the emotional
effect of intense hunger during his
extreme crash diet that he found the
most surprising and difficult challenge
to deal with Brody told the BBC the
Frederick's lost I've experienced
sadness in my life but I didn't know the
desperation that comes with hunger
well there were moments when he wasn't
sure he'd get out of the experience with
the sanity intact saying it took a year
and a half to quote settle back into
things Colin Firth speech for another
Oscar weight performance the sixth and
the Oscar winning the King's Speech it
has to give a number of speeches in
addition to a number of other royal
duties the film has a villain of sorts
in the form of a near debilitating
stammer that ruins nearly every speech
George gives until he hires a vocal
coach
Prince magic author George birth himself
also worked closely with the voice coach
and watch recordings of George speaking
to better emulate both his vocal
shortcomings as well as his physical
mannerisms and nervous ticks when
stammering
Firth immersed himself so deeply in the
role that he admitted in an interview
that he still occasionally lapsed into
the stand when speaking
even briefly stammering during the
interview itself it's worth noting that
this happened in May of 2011 a full
eight months after the film premiered in
September of the previous year judging
by how flawlessly he had not ceded every
syllable in Kingsman the Secret Service
while taking down thugs with an umbrella
of 2014
it looks like bird has since gotten over
the stammer Hugh Laurie house
what's essentially American actor to
play dr. house shortly before hiring a
British actor Hugh Laurie Laurie
apparently got the role because his
American accent on his audition tape was
so convincing nobody realized he was
British the director of the pilot even
pointed to the tape and said see this is
what I want an American guy but really
happy using house so much so the actors
still walking from limp in 2015 after
each three years pretending to have one
onset Laurie also reportedly attempted
to use the load in his leg by
occasionally switching the leg with the
limb something he claims nobody ever
noticed or call them on during filming
or in the years since the show ended oh
interesting
Laurie's acting is so good I'm gonna
make people overlook both is Britishness
and the fact he didn't always live with
the same way despite that being at the
finding aspect of the character Bob
Hoskins Who Framed Roger Rabbit
Hoskins roles was that of alcoholic le
gumshoe any valent in the film Who
Framed Roger Rabbit Hoskins had to spend
several hours a day for eight months
talking to and acting alongside such an
characters horribly there
reiax Hoskins would later note that he
learned how to hallucinate that Roger
and the other characters were actually
there to cope with the dissonance of
constantly hearing their voices but
never seeing them while filming when
shooting finally Hoskins is constantly
talking to himself and even
hallucinating that Roger was sitting in
the same room for months afterwards I
seem to take a much-needed break from
acting Heath Ledger well hello a little
boom never expected that our table
cloths get him an Oscar for Best
Supporting Actor tragically it was a
posthumous award as Leger had died of an
accidental overdose in January 2008 does
it depress you Commissioner to know just
how alone you really are in the years
that followed his premature death rumors
swirled the preparation for the dark
roll had contributed to Ledger's demise
before filming began ledger put himself
in a strict isolation keeping a diary of
disturbing images to enter the realm of
the psychopath he sometimes only slept
two hours of night while filming
according to a November 2007 interview
with the New York Times it was a mixture
of painkillers anti-anxiety drugs and
sleeping pills that ultimately cost
Ledger's death just two months later
Charlie Hunnam American TV and movies
Charlie Hunnam has played everything
from a soccer hooligan to a giant robot
pilot and he's known for his
extraordinarily convincing America's a
try it's making Batman chameleon lighter
British actor is able to convince men
passes American in his various roles you
rescued her you raised her you're not
protecting her now you will holding her
back years of living in the States
however took their toll on Hans actual
real-life accent and when he appeared on
TV in 2013 a plug a movie on Conan he
spoke with the bizarre amalgamation of
various American dialects that prompted
confusion and mockery especially in
Hunnam jwk rounding the side of the
house that he stopped and I'd look to
them and I said so we got business model
Haim spoke about this in 2017 when he
admitted that his accent or lack thereof
had gotten so bad that when you sign on
the star King Arthur legend or the sword
he had to hire a dialect coach to
relearn how to speak with an English
accent I have a first time in my career
my name was above the title it's Charlie
Hunnam boom King haaa
okay here we go Janet Lee weird Janet
Lee is no dealing for one role playing
the character who gets stabbed to death
in the shower early on and Alfred
Hitchcock whales throw up the scene
terrified millions including Lee after
filming wrapped she never felt
comfortable in a shower again in
interviews we noted that she stopped
after watching the scene oh my god could
on the rare occasion she had to take a
shower she would only use it briefly
while staring directly at the door she
might go over all the shower curtain
James Cromwell babe James brought a kind
of actor whose appearance is so
distinctive most people know his face
but not his name he scored one of his
few leading film roles in 1995 babe in
which she was upstaged by a talking pig
but it all worked out given that it was
not
a massive hit but a change crumbles what
turning him from a guy who occasionally
flirted with vegetarianism into a vegan
Cromwell oh happy days with me is life
recalling in his interview with Vice
that he was profoundly affected by
seeing a small piglet react to being put
onto a patch of grass he said quote when
that little pig was put down that big
pigeon saw the blue sky and the green
grass and the see that pig just took off
and said I don't want any part of this
I'm out
Cromwell has been an ardent supporter
ever since I would have set up companies
which understandably now have a small
place in his heart thanks to babe and
its sequel babe to a pig in the city I
know that I'm aware of their suffering
and I know that I have an obligation to
talk about their suffering and to do
something about their suffering
Christopher McDonald happy gilmore
Christopher McDonald isn't exactly in
radio waves performance and happy
gilmore so memorable that generations of
film goers can't look at a picture of
his face without blurting out hey it's
shooter McGavin that's just one roll out
of many in a solid career but it looks
like McDonald doesn't mind being forever
associated with the hot-headed Gulf Pro
McDonald told the a/v Club he took the
role basically because he enjoyed
playing golf and want to turn this
shortly after being off of the script he
was hesitant at first saying he wasn't
eager to get back on a film set after
shooting two movies back to back but
being paid to play golf and hang out
that and Sandler seemed like a pretty
sweet deal according to Donald his golf
game got sick since he played for five
hours a day six days a week while
filming Cohen's genetic bonus now that
he's synonymous with shooter McGavin he
basically gets to play golf for free for
the rest of his
oh cool mister
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to kind of a weird one to
end it on right I'm assuming you're
gonna end it on I'm like the most yeah
well we're like oh they were traumatized
forever
[Music]
[Applause]
this guy actually got a lot of perks
from being this guy Oh Barney
that's so crazy that Charlie's just like
he can't talk in an English accent
anymore The Pianist was a good one oh my
god yeah I mean I I was kind of moved by
that one yeah and the James Cromwell one
about babe yes because while I'm usually
the one who is fascinated by like oh
they couldn't shake the character when
they come out from a life experience
where my perception of things has just
really changed since I did this role I
find that kind of moving and inspiring I
really but you know these guys are all
pretentious [ __ ] they should just
get out of their own heads and get back
to work get back to work you're acting
yeah why isn't there will be blood in
here what Daniel day-lewis just only be
about Daniel day-lewis in my opinion he
has a hard time shaking rules yes he
lives in them and the character for so
long
DiCaprio actually for the Aviators I had
to go in therapy because he couldn't
shake the OCD tendencies yeah which
makes sense you know a lot of times you
hear things about actors or I could see
how someone who's not really aware of
certain crafts that you go that sounds a
little pretentious come on right but it
is such a psychological game yeah that
you find yourself thinking in life a
little different like the character
especially we gonna starve yourself or
live with like OCD and I don't have to
get used to that he wakes up a certain
way and moves a certain way like it kind
of takes over your body just like when
you hang out with friends if you here
with a certain friend and they have like
a certain tick or they move a certain
way and you hang out with them for like
let's say you go on vacation for like a
week or two weeks you start doing or
speaking in their tone of voice
doing those like weird tics that they
have they always have that thing where
they've said like couples sometimes
start to look alike yes because you
start taking on each other's language
the expressions yes it just happens
sometimes and in terms of like craft of
art it's nice when I write a story
they're all on YouTube all my stories
are on YouTube I you know are they yeah
maybe I don't know and why no one
watches my stories my scripts
oh but something's gonna read story Tara
I'll think so much about especially the
main character if it's a dark backstory
you end up developing this whole life
and sometimes your writing dialogue you
get so caught up in who they are why
they are the way they are and I
sometimes find myself I'm kind of in a
dark place now right like I'm having a
hard time getting rid of that and that's
just from writing a carrot yeah getting
so into writing something but you're
doing it for hours on end that I can
only imagine for an actor who has to
know the physicality the whole backstory
of all these things of how that can
change you we have to live in that I
would never want Daniel day-lewis to
take on a show right because when you
hear about Hugh Laurie doing the show
I've never heard of that of someone
doing a TV show and having the hardest
time shaking that off right like the
Charlie Hunnam thing with the accent I
know Mel Gibson had a similar thing oh
really because he was born in the States
but he grew up in Australia and if you
watch like the first Lethal Weapon movie
or the first Mad Max movie you can hear
his Australian accent yeah but then over
time his accent just went away this is
if she evaporated straight through the
Wolves that's the same thing if you're a
mean if you're if you're sitting around
doing like a British accent for like
quite a while yeah and then you just
start to talk like that
mhm do you see what I mean yeah you're
nailing it they're like oh my god where
are you from the Harry Potter land do
you know I mean yeah yeah the British
people love it I live over there and I'm
like
no centerless I don't even took Latin
and seen me alive in below
look the British people were looking
like that guys oh yeah some of these are
very unique cases to me like Bob Hoskins
on the Roger Rabbit set hallucinating
yeah because he has to use his
imagination so much in order to give a
convincing performance it's like where's
that fine line of personal life and
acting one thing that always comes to
mind for me is remember when Christian
Bale lost his ship yes yeah yeah that
was a funny I still listen to audio from
time to time it just makes me laugh are
you there are the times where I'm like
oh I get it like I say that where I'm
like I get why Christian Bale losses
losses mind yeah just just a little bit
okay Christian Bale can play a rageful
bad man
yeah at American Psycho and we go great
I love it yeah but then you hear that
audio of him losing his [ __ ] on what
everyone's like forget I'm like but it
takes that level of like yes you
shouldn't treat people that way
absolutely agree with that the thing is
is that sometimes you have to
psychologically get to such a place tone
or portray this authenticity yeah that
sometimes it bleeds into your personal
life so I don't think it's right to
crucify someone in the social media
world but also you haven't been on set
you're putting the amount of energy that
needs to put into those roles and you do
multiple takes on that and that one take
was going so well and you were in it and
then some guy ruins it I get why he
would be angry again let's bring it down
a bit Christian but I I understand it
takes a lot of work they do like most of
what he does I mean everyone's human
things Bob Hoskins on Roger Rabbit I've
never heard is every actor I imagine my
cardboard box buddies around me some
in there now see what happens yeah I
just reenact trades with him so much and
then I just sit there and go oh no it's
fine and that my oh he's not even there
imagine Tara losing her mind and a body
horror movie yeah everyone thinks I
already do anyway Michael Jordan on
Space Jam went crazy he really believed
yeah really immersed himself God blast
Michael Jordan he is a committed actor
but seriously does make sense with Roger
I he was talking to nobody always all of
the time and he does a great job he does
a great job so it makes perfect sense
why are you really good at that yeah I
believe in life that you become what you
think and feel about you know yes come
that energy transfers other than a joke
I would never actually believe or think
these guys are just pretentious humans
you know like grace if your mind is
going there all the time you would
totally become something I find it more
impressive when you could kind of just
turn it off when you can you go from
like this crazy person up yeah I'm not
that person now you know exactly that's
more pressin to me to be able to really
disassociate and differentiate between
the two
I know Sandra Bullock is really good at
that somebody works with her on set and
was like she's really good at being in a
scene getting ready to cry but not being
like I need a minute
she's like goes does it and then the
second is done she's done and like cool
so do you guys know what's our next
thing well everyone has a different
approach to what makes it work there's
no yeah one way to be an actor no
there's not at all some actors don't do
any backstory and they just kind of
trust their subconscious and go into it
and let it go and then there are other
actresses what's-her-name
Kristen Stewart thank you so much yeah
show doesn't it Twilight movie thing's
great her Jennifer Lawrence doesn't
really do a lot of backstory okay crazy
cuz she's an amazing acts on people like
Daniel day-lewis feel like this is the
only way I feel confident you know
performance is to go this level of depth
you know I don't do any backstory I
didn't read the script I just go give it
to me cold yeah I enter and what's the
line in there as greetings from handles
great I've got it let's roll
season's greetings hold on I've got it
from pandas and then we move on we do
the whole day like that and they go wow
you didn't do
any prep work and I go don't you love it
and they go you sure do it makes sense
where you book so many non-union
commercial yeah top of it today died
anyway this is a good video you can
catch Tara have flappers in Burbank
sometime soon sometimes you can catch me
there other times you can catch me on my
youtube channel yes go this is a good
accent but before I let Tara venture
offer to this accent I wanted to give a
shout out to someone at our patreon a
man named Daniel Gallagher can you do a
Scottish accent he's Scottish
yes
oh that's not pretty John you Daniel
Gallagher
Daniel gatha can you roll your R's gala
Connor Oh Daniel Gallagher on your
Gallagher no Gallagher if I were to do
it Scottish accent I have to Disney
where I talk to this side of my face
Danielle gala got her done your garlic I
mean I talk a lot about movies and
you've had your name set a variety of
different ways it's the new I am Groot
around the real rejects look at that
Gallagher gal I got it Danielle guy like
Adam Gallagher dude Gallagher or like go
girl you see a lot of times when I do
shoutouts I like to go off of the
interaction I've had with the patrons
and then you know really work off that
sure but I figured let's let Terry shout
out complete you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click notification
bells follow Tara on YouTube and social
media check us on patreon we got a
full-length TV show reaction watch along
weekly Q&A is John does mucus video
coverage see you soon